you know the olympian who she got third
place in the olympic trials for throwing
a hammer and then she used the
opportunity
to disrespect the american flag and in
so doing our entire country and all of
her countrymen
remember that and then she wants to go
represent the country at the olympics so
this this lady
i'm not even going to say her name i
don't i don't think we need to reward
this this individual's temper tantrum
and and anti-american activism
by saying her name and giving her
publicity which is exactly what she
wants
but she went on some television show
that i haven't haven't heard of
and she explained herself she said
she wasn't not disrespecting america she
just she just
hates the star-spangled banner
know your history you know the full song
of the national anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america
our blood being slain and and piltered
all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
uh the third stanza of the of the
star spangled banner does not refer to
slaves blood being slain slang and
piltered
all over the ground because those aren't
words i mean
i suppose they're slang is a word but it
doesn't it doesn't mean what she thinks
it means and
i've never heard of piltered i don't so
it's not english that's why
that's not that's why that's not what's
happening in the third stanza
second of all the meaning of that verse
which is uh refers to the
hireling and slave and about how how no
refuge will save the hireling and slave
the meaning of that verse is really not
clear in
in some place it may refer to american
slaves but it also very
likely refers to the german troops for
instance that the british were hiring
and who who were purchased from german
princes it
may refer to the british process of
impressment uh
the author of the star spangled banner
never made clear what he meant by that
expression
uh regardless though let's just say it's
even right let's say it's referring to
slaves who went and fought for the
british and and the
spangled banner talks about how terrible
they are nobody sings the third verse
who's whoever sings the third verse of
the star-spangled banner
nobody it's a completely contrived
problem because
you're using the excuse of a line about
a slave that
may or may not refer to american slaves
as a justification for getting rid of
the whole star-spangled banner as part
of the project of reframing american
history
there's there was a national anthem well
now there's a black national anthem
which is sometimes played at public
events
there's an independence day well now
there's the juneteenth
national independence day the new
national independence day there is the
traditional understanding of america
centered around the goodness of the
country and the founding fathers now
there's the new reframing of america put
forward by the 1619 project
it's just a new shift this woman says if
you know your history you know this
she doesn't know her history she doesn't
barely knows the english language but
what she does know is ideology and she
doesn't even know that she knows it
this is the unknown
known this sick ideology that is totally
contrary to our country and contrary to
her flourishing and flourishing of all
of our countrymen
has just seeped in and she's not she's
just swimming in it she's not
not even aware of it she goes on though
she says yeah i hate the national anthem
i totally disrespected it
but i still want to play in the olympics
i never said
that i didn't want to go to the olympic
games that's why i competed and got
third and made the team
i never said that i hated the country
never said that all i said was i respect
my people
enough to not stand or acknowledge
something that disrespects them
i love my people point blank period i
mean i learned that family matters
despite the economic oppression that we
faced growing up
you know i still have my family and my
grandmother she did
everything she could to make sure that
we survived and had a roof over our
head and that's special very interesting
language she's using here so first it's
so silly she goes i'm not disrespecting
the country uh well if you disrespect
the star-spangled banner
which is the symbol of the country you
are disrespecting the country if you
disrespect the symbol you're
disrespecting the symbolized
that's why symbols symbolize things well
i still want to play in the olympics
yeah i know you do but
it's not about you lady it's about the
team which represents the country
then she uses this subtle light she says
yeah we faced
economic oppression growing up
oppression not
we had economic troubles not we had
economic suffering which
a lot of us have probably all of us have
at some point in our lives or the vast
majority of us do
oppression it was somebody else's fault
it wasn't because a family member ran
away it wasn't because a family member
didn't didn't go work hard it wasn't
because someone made bad choices it
wasn't because someone
wasn't able to overcome it wasn't it was
oppression
somebody did this to us through no fault
of our
own is that really how life works is
life really that simple i don't think so
then she says it's not i'm not saying i
hate the country i just love my people
what do you mean your people to use a
popular rejoinder what do you mean
you're people
who are your people here she's he's
she's obviously implying black people
and she's saying that the national
anthem
is against black people this
star-spangled banner symbol of the whole
country
is opposed to black people and so when
push comes to shove she's going to side
with the black people over america
because she sees them
as being at odds i don't see them as
being at odds
i actually the only way we can have a
country is if we believe that our people
are the american people
there are gradations of identity there's
a national identity
state identity local identity religious
identity racial identity
family identity the basic political
union she says i love my family
right in order to have a flourishing
society all of those things need to be
in order of accord in
in subsidiarity to use a technical term
okay
they can't be opposed to one another but
increasingly what we're seeing
is division between well actually even
within the family especially the left is
trying to sew that
and then between the family and the
state and
the state and the country
and the races obviously they're trying
to gin up racial division and sexual
division they're trying to put that all
against one another
in order for the country to flourish
your people has to include all of those
things
down the family up to the race and the
community and everything all the way up
to the nation ideology has warped that
it's taught her a lot of things she
knows that she doesn't even know that
she knows i'm glad you like that clip
we've got a whole episode it's called
unknown knowns
check it out right here on youtube you
can get it also on apple podcast spotify
all those different places
you can also buy my book the national
bestseller speechless controlling words
controlling minds thank you so much to
everyone who has ordered that book
already really appreciate
all of you if you haven't gotten it yet
go get it see you next time
[Music]
you